jason marty i just don't know what to
call you
you guys look so beautiful too i gotta
give her a shout out thank you i dressed
her yeah i thought you know pretty cool
female fashion
what did you learn out there in the
ozarks i started in female fashion not a
lot of people know that
well
i'm telling you what are you and paul
rudd taking because y'all are looking
ageless mr benjamin buttons paul and i
carpool down to tijuana a couple times a
month to do some experimental stuff not
a lot of injections it's mostly creams
but it's working pretty well we're both
65.
folks earn it here first
wow from female fashion to going to
tijuana with ron you're very nice well i
tell you i'm going to miss being on this
ride with the birds what are you going
to miss most about portraying marty bird
and being with your tv family
just a boring answer working with good
people you know i mean like imagine if
you weren't working with him you'd be
working with like incredible people but
it's uh it's just you know when you get
lucky and you get a good group together
you know
it's fun and there's good product and
it's that simple it was phenomenal what
a run and then
what did you think when you read the
final script what was your initial
reaction
that i can't believe we all kill each
other it's um lies y'all that is not a
spoiler no no no no no that's what
happened no um
it's uh it's just
more great writing and
a really
[Music]
smart kind of subtle measured ending
that's very consistent with the quality
of chris mundy's work and his staff and
um just proud to be able to be in front
of the camera on it but you also bring
it to life twofold in front of the
camera as marty bird and behind the
camera as the director what did it mean
to you to be able to
bring it home it was i didn't think i
was going to be able to actually direct
the finale because of other stuff and
that that work pushed and so i got to
direct that uh that final episode kind
of like we started the whole thing and
be able to kind of cross the finish line
together it was it was really fortunate
i think we need to cross another finish
line with a movie
yeah yeah well we'd all have to rise
from the dead though to do that you know
like exhume the body them on to you and
then we'd all have already watched that
fix the bullet holes in our heads and
okay okay chris wiped uh the goat jar
the goat cookie jar what did you swipe
from set
memories oh whatever jason give me
something good i know you swiped
something
um i i took a little something each year
just dumb crap that wouldn't mean it
i well i took a bullet casing from one
of the blanks we used to kill one of the
characters
and so that was kind of cool laura told
me she took her wedding ring
took her wedding ring
i haven't taken mine off
[Music]